In this demo, we allow the user to
move the ball around by flicking it.
Here's how we define a flick.
If a touch or click starts inside
the ball, then we've started a flick.
When the touch or click is released,
then we give the ball some velocity,
proportional to the vector between where
the flick started and where it ended.
Let's check out the demo in the course
code to see how this is done.
So here we are inside our
BouncingBall class, and
we've overridden the touchDown
method from InputProcessor.
The first thing we need to do,
is to translate the point that the user
touched from screen coordinates
to world coordinates.
Since the viewport handles
the projection from world coordinates to
screen coordinates, it also has an
unproject method that does the opposite.
Next, we use the dst method on Vector2,
to see if the distance between
the position of the ball and
the worldClick is less than
the radius of the ball.
If the touch is inside the radius,
then we start a flick.
And then we save off
the coordinates of the touch.
We've also overridden touchUp.
When a touch is released,
if we were in the middle of flicking
a ball, we unset that flag.
We unproject to the location
where the touch was released
from screen coordinates
to world coordinates.
We compute vector between where the
flick started to where the flick ended,
and then we add that vector
to the velocity of the ball,
multiplied by this FLICK_MULTIPLIER.